welcome back to cbs this morning
hundreds of thousands of amazon
employees are watching one of the most
significant
unionization drives in a generation
workers at an amazon warehouse near
birmingham alabama
are voting on whether to join a retail
workers union
their colleagues around the country are
wondering how that will affect them
mark strassman is at that fulfillment
center in bessemer alabama where he
spoke to
some of the workers mark good morning
good morning anthony in two shifts a day
here 5 800 workers
sort package and ship the sort of amazon
boxes that many of us get delivered
delivered at home they make more than 15
an hour which is more than double the
minimum wage
but some of them tell us the company
refuses to hear their complaints
and frustrations michael foster is a
union organizer
and early this morning we found him
outside the amazon warehouse at shift
change
where he's campaigned for votes since
last october
amazon is uh treating the people of
disrespectful
they basically telling the people if you
don't want to avoid
by the way we work you can go find
another job somewhere else
according to the union roughly 85
percent of the workers at this massive
warehouse
are black most are women many complain
about grueling work
unsafe conditions with inadequate
bathroom and meal breaks
we're being treated like we're prisoners
who's there to get a job done jennifer
bates and daryl richardson
both work at the warehouse what's your
biggest frustration there
job security respect and safe just
your safety well being the community
don't realize
is what's going on behind the curtain
what are the people they're going
through just to make sure that we're
getting our packages
it's time for us to make a stand it's
time for some changes
frustrated workers contacted the retail
wholesale and department store union
celebrities like danny glover support
them martin luther king said the best
anti-poverty program he knew of
was the union and that still remains so
more than 60 years after he said make
that statement and this week
president biden weighed in every worker
should have a free and fair choice to
join a union
but they are amazon and this is alabama
the e-commerce behemoth is fighting the
union drive in this right-to-work state
in a statement the company told us if
the union vote passes it will impact
everyone at the site and it's important
associates understand
what that means for them and their
day-to-day life working at amazon
amazon worker don hogue will vote no i
have yet to personally
encounter anyone that is pro union
i do not see a point in paying somebody
to do something i'm fully capable to do
for myself and that being advocating
but the union believes these workers
need a voice
and they'll deliver the votes despite
long odds
if you put enough heart in anything that
you do
you can do anything even in alabama even
in alabama
we have not been able to organize in
alabama as we wish we could
but things are meant to change
this is a vote by mail and will go on
until march
29th the union expects this to be a
close vote
but whichever side wins the loser could
challenge the outcome
tony all right mark thank you very much
very consequential vote i understand not
understanding why you're paying somebody
what are they going to do for you
but you realize what they may do for you
when you need them and they're not there
yeah i don't i don't know the right
answer here to union or not to unionize
but they're certainly raising some very
um troubling issues that i think need to
be addressed
it's and as we pointed out at the
beginning it's very it's we haven't seen
a unionization battle
of this significant in quite a long time
i know union membership had been
declining for years it may be back on
the uptick
all right mark thank you very much